we gave
you know this future life award we gave
it
the first time to this guy vasily
archibald you know he was
on most people haven't even heard of him
yeah can you say who he is vasily
arkhipov
he has in my opinion
made the greatest positive contribution
to humanity of any human in in modern
history
and maybe it sounds like hyperbole here
like i'm just over the top but let me
tell you the story and i think maybe
you'll agree
so during the cuban missile crisis
we americans first didn't know that the
russians had sent four submarines
but we caught two of them and we didn't
know
that so we dropped practice depth
charges on the one that he was on
to try to force it to the surface
but we didn't know that this nuclear
submarine actually was a nuclear
submarine with a nuclear torpedo
we also didn't know that they had
authorization to launch it without
clearance from moscow and we also didn't
know that they were running out of
electricity their batteries were almost
dead
they were running out of oxygen sailors
were fainting left and right
the temperature was about 110
120 fahrenheit on board it was really
hellish conditions really just
kind of doomsday and at that point these
giant explosions start happening from
americans dropping these
the captain thought world war iii had
begun they decided that
they were going to launch the nuclear
torpedo and one of them shouted you know
we're all going to die but we're not
going to disgrace our navy you know
we don't know what would have happened
if there had to be a giant mushroom
cloud all of a sudden
you know and against the americans but
since everybody had their hands on the
triggers
pretty you don't have to be too creative
to think that it could have led to an
all-out nuclear war
and in which case we wouldn't be having
this conversation now right what
actually took place
was they needed three people to to
approve this
the captain had said yes there was the
communist party political officer he
also said yes let's do it
and the third man was this guy
vasiliyakipov
who said yet yeah he for some reason he
was just more chill than the others and
he was the right man at the right time
i don't want us as a species rely on the
right person being there at the right
time
you know we track down his family
living in relative poverty outside
moscow
when we flew his daughter he had passed
away
and flew them to london they had never
been to the west even it was incredibly
moving so get to honor them for this
uh the next year we gave this future
life award to
stanislav petrov have you heard of him
yes so he
he was in charge of the soviet early
warning uh
station which was built with soviet
technology
and honestly not that reliable it said
that there were five u.s missiles coming
in
again if they had launched at that point
we probably wouldn't be having this
conversation he decided
based on just mainly gut instinct to
just not
tell not to not escalate this and i'm
very glad he wasn't replaced by an ai
that was just
automatically following orders and then
we gave the third one to matthew
messelstan
last year we gave this award to
to these guys who actually use
technology for good
not avoiding something bad but for
something good
the guys who eliminated this disease
which is way worse than covet
that had killed a half a billion people
in in the past it's violent century
smallpox right so
we mentioned it earlier coved on average
kills less than one percent of people
who get it smallpox about 30 percent
and um they just ultimately viktor
zdanov
and bill feige most of my colleagues
have never heard of either of them
um one american one russian they
did this amazing effort not only what
was done able to get the us and the
soviet union to team up against smallpox
during the cold war
but bill feige came up with this
ingenious strategy for making it
actually
go all the way to defeat the disease
without funding for vaccinating everyone
and as a result we haven't had any
we went from 15 million deaths the year
i was born in smallpox
so what do we have in covet now a little
bit short of 2 million right yes
to zero deaths of course this year and
forever
there have been 200 million people they
estimate who would have died
since then by smallpox had it not been
for this so isn't science awesome
can't that when you use it for good and
i would the reason we want to celebrate
these sort of people is is to remind
them of this
science is so awesome when you use it
for good
and those uh those awards actually the
variety there paint's a very interesting
picture so
the the the first two are looking at
it's kind of exciting to think that
these these average humans
in some sense that they're products of
you know billions of
other humans that came before them
evolution and some
little you said gut you know but there's
something
in there that that uh
stopped the annihilation of the human
race
and that's a magical thing but that's
like this deeply human thing
and then there's the other aspect where
that's also very human
which is to build solution to the
to the existential crises that we're
facing like to build it to take the
responsibility and to take
come up with different technologies and
so on yeah and both of those are
deeply human the gut and and the mind
whatever that is the best is when they
work together
i wish i could have met him of course
but he had passed away
he was really a fantastic military
officer
combining all all the best traits that
we in america admire in our military
because first of all he was very loyal
of course he never even told anyone
about this
during his whole life even though you
think he had some bragging rights right
but he just was like this is just
business just doing my job
it only came out later after his death
and and second
the reason he did the right thing was
not because he was some sort of liberal
or some sort not because he was
just oh you know peace and love
it was partly because he had been the
captain on another submarine that had a
nuclear reactor meltdown
and it was his heroism that
helped contain this that's why he died
of cancer later also but he's seen many
of his crew members die
and i think for him that gave him this
gut feeling that you know
if there's a nuclear war between the u.s
and the soviet union
the whole world is going to go through
what i saw
my dear crew members suffered through it
wasn't just an abstract thing for him
i think it was real and second though
not just the gut the mind right he he
was for some reason
very level-headed personality a very
smart guy
which is exactly what we want our best
fighter pilots to be also right i i
never forget neil armstrong when he's
landing on the moon and almost running
out of gas
and he doesn't even change when they say
30 seconds he doesn't even change the
tone of voice just keeps going archipop
i think was just like that
so when the explosion starts going off
and his captain is screaming and we
should nuke them and all
he's like
i don't think the americans are trying
to sink us
i think they're trying to send us a
message
that's a pretty badass yes coolness
because he said yeah
if they wanted to sink us no and he said
listen listen
it's alternating one loud explosion on
the left
one on the right one on the left one on
the right he was the only one who
noticed this pattern
and it is like i think this is them
trying to send us a signal
that they want us to surface and they're
not going to sink us
and somehow
this is how he then managed to
ultimately with his
combination of gut and also just
cool analytical thinking was able to
de-escalate the whole thing
and uh yeah so this is some of the best
in humanity i guess coming back to what
we talked about earlier is the
combination of the neural network the
institute
you know with uh i'm getting the tearing
up here getting emotional but
he was just he is one of my superheroes
com having both the the heart you know
and the mind combined and especially in
that time uh there's something about the
i mean this is a very in america people
are used to this kind of idea of being
the individual
um of like on your own thinking yeah
i think uh under in the soviet union
under communism
it's actually much harder to do that oh
yeah he didn't even
he even got he didn't get any accolades
either when he came back for this right
uh they just wanted to hush the whole
thing up yeah there's echoes of that
with chernobyl there's all kinds of
um uh that's one
that's that's a really hopeful thing
that amidst
big centralized powers whether it's
companies or states
there's still the power of the
individual to think on their own to act
but i think we need to think of people
like this
not as a panacea we can always count on
but rather as
a wake-up call you know so because of
them
because of archipelago we are alive to
learn from this lesson
to learn from the fact that we shouldn't
keep playing russian roulette and almost
have a nuclear war by mistake
now and then because relying on luck is
not a good long-term strategy
if you keep playing russian inlet over
and over again the probability of
surviving just drops exponentially with
time yeah
and if you have some probability of
having an accidental new core every year
the probability of not having one
also drops exponentially i think we can
do better than that so i i think
uh the message is very clear once in a
while [ __ ] happens
and there's a lot of very concrete
things we can do
to reduce the risk of things like that
happening in the first place
you